hey guys i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen in today's video we are
going to be tackling
a big topic weight loss surgery so we're
going to be talking about some of the
common types of bariatric surgery
some of the motivators or outcomes of
surgery and most importantly the
significant risks associated with some
of these procedures
now i want to flag that this video is
not meant to be a promotion for
or lecture against bariatric surgery i
fully respect your body autonomy and i'm
definitely going to be keeping
my bias out of this to simply state what
some of the evidence says so that way
you can make some informed decisions
about your life
i believe that we are so lucky to have
options when it comes to our health
but it's still really important to
understand all of these options
from all sides i totally understand that
this content may be triggering for some
of my viewers
so if this is the kind of content that
maybe you want to skip ahead on
or you don't want to watch don't worry
there's lots of great content on the way
also of course i want to remind you that
my merch line is now available
this is my favorite snack sweatshirt so
i think just really fun
and cheeky and it's great for hanging
out in
so you can definitely check out the link
in the description below but also just
check out the shop page
on my website before we dive in just as
a reminder
the information in this video is for
entertainment and educational purposes
only and you should always seek out the
help of a registered dietitian
and your doctor for your unique case
okay so let's get into this
first of all what is weight loss surgery
aka
bariatric surgery it ultimately involves
making changes to the digestive system
to of course aid in weight loss so
bariatric surgery
generally achieves weight loss in two
major ways
number one is through restriction so in
some types of procedures the surgeon
decreases the size of the stomach to
limit the amount of food that it can
hold
so common procedures that achieve
restriction are things like
laparoscopic adjustable gastric banding
aka the lap band
as well as sleeve gastrectomy number two
is malabsorption now in this type of
bariatric surgery procedure the surgeon
limits the amount of nutrients that the
body absorbs
by bypassing a part of the small
intestine so
common procedures that achieve
malabsorption are the ruin y
gastric bypass and the biliopancreatic
diversion with duodenal switch also
known as the duodenal switch
so now let's talk a bit about some of
the potential motivators
and outcomes of weight loss surgery the
first being of course
weight loss now considering its main
purpose is of course to help people
reduce their weight when they haven't
had success with other avenues
research has consistently shown that
bariatric surgery is effective
at helping patients lose between 47 to
70 percent of their excess weight
having said that research has also found
that bariatric surgery
doesn't promise long-term results
necessarily
one study found that excess weight loss
in patients with the laparoscopic sleeve
gastrectomy for example
was 77 after a year it then decreased to
56
after five years now other research has
found that weight regain
weight was around 14.1 percent in five
years after weight loss surgery
while another study found that only 40
of gastric bypass patients maintained at
least 30 percent
of their weight loss after 12 years
these numbers
may be more promising than lifestyle
ventures alone
however given the physical and mental
cost associated with bariatric surgery
it's not necessarily a foolproof one and
done procedure either
number two is improvements in glycemic
control
one study by bushwald al found that
bariatric surgery achieved complete
diabetes resolution
in 76.8 of its subjects however
long-term data shows a potential
recurrence of hyperglycemia for some
patients years after the procedure
while it's unclear how many patients
will relapse because of a lack of
long-term studies
research does suggest that there is a
significant percentage
somewhere between 30 and 50 of patients
who will likely experience a relapse in
their diabetes symptoms
next is a decrease in mortality one
meta-analysis including over 44
000 participants from eight different
trials found a reduced risk of global
mortality after bariatric surgery
compared with no surgery research has
also shown that weight loss surgery can
reduce mortality
in specific people and populations by as
much as 30 percent
so not surprisingly bariatric surgery
may be a promising option for some
individuals but it certainly is not
perfect and is not without its risks
now let's shift gears for a second and
discuss some of the long-term concerns
of weight loss surgeries
starting with common physical health
concerns number one
malnutrition and malabsorption now
depending on the procedure
some weight loss surgeries completely
bypass a large portion of the small
intestine
making it almost impossible for your gut
to absorb all of the vitamins and
minerals from food
and increasing the risk of malnutrition
so one study for example found an iron
deficiency incidence of up to 50
in premenopausal women who had had
gastric bypass surgery
but not in the restrictive procedure
group
likewise protein deficiency has been
reported
in about seven to twenty one percent of
patients after undergoing the duodenal
switch procedure
because of the alteration in bilaria and
pancreatic function
electrolyte imbalance is another major
complication of bariatric surgery
and that can result in neuromuscular
disorders
and arrhythmias of the heart because of
these risks
lifelong monitoring of these nutritional
complications is definitely necessary
to avoid any long-term issues number two
serious gi disorders so nausea and
vomiting are
very common outcomes of weight loss
surgery sometimes this is because of
overeating or eating certain foods that
are not compatible with your new
digestive tract
and function and size but dumping
syndrome
which is basically when foods enter the
small intestine too quickly
can also cause nausea as well as
vomiting
diarrhea and dizziness so for that
reason patients are instructed to
really focus on keeping their portion
sizes small and of course
eating very mindfully and slowly number
three
relapse rates now considering the risks
and lifestyle shift that is required in
bariatric surgery
nobody wants to believe that weight
regain or diabetes relapse is a common
experience
but as i mentioned earlier these things
do commonly happen
now even with these relapses the
outcomes may arguably still be
potentially
better than they might have been with
strict dieting alone for some
individuals
but still i think it's important to just
note that weight loss surgery is not
necessarily a
fix it and forget it kind of procedure
for a lot of patients
now maybe more concerning let's talk
about the mental health risks
starting with an increased risk for
eating disorders the incidence of binge
eating disorder has been estimated to be
as high as 69
in bariatric patients and night eating
syndrome is present in as many as
42 these numbers are
truly shocking while many patients
report vomiting after eating as a result
of
overeating or not being able to tolerate
the food with their new gi system
there's also a percentage of patients
that are vomiting
to ultimately control their weight and
or shape some researchers have suggested
that the common gastrointestinal
symptoms like vomiting that are
just ultimately common after weight loss
surgery
may almost help facilitate or perpetuate
the development of eating disorder
behaviors
it can be very difficult to classify
certain behaviors as disordered
because ultimately some behaviors are
kind of taught
and encouraged after bariatric surgery
as a way to relieve discomfort
number two addiction transfer
researchers have found that patients are
more prone to alcohol abuse
and this type of addiction may be
happening as a way to
substitute eating this is known as
addiction transfer
since a bariatric patient cannot really
use food anymore as a coping mechanism
they instead may turn to drugs and or
alcohol to comfort them
in a 2015 study 18.4
of patients developed an alcohol abuse
disorder within three years of having
the rygb surgery some researchers
hypothesized
that alcohol abuse is common among
bariatric patients
because of the structural changes made
to the digestive system
those changes make alcohol more easily
absorbed which is why patients have a
greater response to the effects of
alcohol
in one study 84 percent of patients who
consumed alcohol after bariatric surgery
experienced intoxicating effects after
consuming even a very small amount
next let's talk about depression suicide
and overall mental health
a lot of the time before surgery even
takes place
bariatric candidates already have a
history of depression
or other mental illnesses they've likely
been exposed to bullying and fat
shaming leading to disordered eating and
or substance abuse
according to a study from yale
university about 13
of bariatric surgery patients experience
an increase in depression
after surgery in a large 2016 study
researchers found that patients who had
undergone the rygb
surgery were three times more likely to
attempt suicide
than the general population and when
compared to the world health
organization suicide rates for the
general population
researchers found a four-fold increased
risk of death by suicide
among bariatric surgery patients to give
us some greater insight on weight loss
surgeries
i've invited kirsten ackerman to chat
with us kirsten
is a registered dietitian that
specializes in health at every size and
intuitive eating
she also has an amazing podcast that i
definitely recommend called intuitive
bites
so i'm going to link to that in the
description below
now kirsten actually worked in a
bariatric clinic for a few years
and has gotten some really amazing
insights to share
well hi kirsten thank you so much for
joining us today
thank you for having me i'm really
excited to chat with you as someone who
has worked in a bariatric clinic
why do you believe that there's such
high rates of things like depression and
suicide and disordered eating in a lot
of the patients
how much weight stigma in the medical
system i mean they're they're the ones
that are most highly
impacted by this um so that's like one
massive thing
many of these people do have disordered
eating prior
prior to going forward with surgery you
know the mental health assessment that's
being done
yes it's it's screening for eating
disorders
but from my experience many
disordered eating behaviors are slipping
through right
because partly because they're so
normalized in our culture that they're
like oh yeah of course
you're in a larger body and you're you
know engaging in these disordered
behaviors
um so that so of course that's going to
carry on to after surgery
but things like suicide and and also
like turning to
other substances right becoming addicted
to other substances
after surgery is common because you're
taking away
something that may have been a coping
skill for some of these people which is
food and then you're just kind of you're
they're not allowed
they can't really use that in the same
way so they turn to other things
and things like depression or suicidal
ideation just kind of bubble to the
surface
right really interesting insights and
absolutely i think that's what the
evidence also
has really been showing so with your
learning of haze and intuitive eating
how has your view of weight loss
surgeries changed yeah so i
very strongly now believe that other
routes should be explored prior to
surgery um
i think that you know my view overall of
the surgery is that
the industry the weight loss surgery
industry is so
embedded in the fat is bad
fat is inherently unhealthy narrative
and that weight loss at all costs is
the right thing um that i just i have so
many
issues with the industry um i want to be
really careful
here not to attack the individual
because there's many reasons that
individuals might pursue this
um and that's not their fault but as the
industry as far as the industry goes and
just like
with its roots and its overall approach
i think it's really problematic
um i do think other avenues should be
explored before surgery
the problem is i think that the way that
our culture currently would take that
statement is
that people should try to lose weight
through all these different avenues
with different diets or what other
whatever mechanism
and from the health and every size
perspective from my approach
i would say that we need to stop trying
to force
larger body people into smaller bodies
and rather take the approach of how can
i
best support their health their
nutrition their nourishment
their you know engagement and joyful
movement and allow their body to do
without what it will
it may result in weight loss it may not
but we can support them
and make them healthier by taking these
other approaches
amazing obviously this video is not
meant to shame any individual for
choosing bariatric surgery
um but to ultimately just inform them of
some of those risks and and some of the
outcomes so
in your experience for patients who have
chosen to embark on this journey
what are some ways to potentially help
minimize some of these risks that we
talked about both physical
but also a lot of the mental health
risks that we mentioned the suicide
depression
eating disorders etc yeah so i think
that it is
so important that people who are going
through this process
first of all have support from in their
social lives like from their family
um but also even more importantly
has the support of a therapist and
hopefully elite inclusive dietitian
who's you know
gonna really support their their
nourishment after surgery uh but having
you know a dietitian
a therapist especially you know a
therapist that's going to help them
through maybe some of the issues they
had around disorder
disordered eating prior surgery helped
them to understand
the impact of the weight stigma that
they likely
experienced right because they're
existing in our culture in a larger body
and really just have that support as
they're navigating
the really really intense post-op phase
yeah no absolutely i think that's that
those are some really great observations
okay so now let's talk about intuitive
eating post
surgery this is the big question is it
possible for people to have an
intuitive eating lifestyle after
undergoing you know one of these
surgeries
and how can you incorporate some or all
of the principles
into your life post-surgery yeah so
short answer is
absolutely yes you can have you know you
can go on this intuitive eating journey
and reconnect your body after surgery
but it is different than if you hadn't
gone through surgery um
so certain principles like you know
honoring your hunger and feeling your
fullness
are much different after surgery because
your body is either
like many people experience not having
hunger signals
right after surgery for many people it
comes back in time and that is actually
very normal
um but in the beginning if you you know
kind of take the principle as honoring
your hunger and like
from the perspective of oh i should only
eat when i'm hungry then you know that's
going to be problematic
um but looking at it in a nuanced way
of like okay i'm gonna honor my hunger
when it's there
sure because my body deserves that and
also i need to make sure that i'm you
know
practicing nourishment for self-care
even if the hunger isn't present
right um and then feeling fullness can
be really different after surgery as
well because
it can come in honestly it can be a
really traumatic experience for people
after surgery because they might take
one bite
bite of something and have a really
negative response to it and then the
next time they eat it it's fine
so it can just be really scary honestly
but
um i think taking it from the lens of
listening to your body taking your
body's feedback and trying to understand
it
so that the next time you nourish it you
know you can try to take that feedback
and
you know eek in a way that's hopefully
going to be feeling okay for you so it's
it's really just it's awareness and this
using the feedback from your body
to inform your future decisions around
food
yeah i i can i think that's some great
advice so thank you
so much for that kirsten i your your
insight into this world is so
valuable because you've you know you've
seen it from both sides so it's really
so interesting to hear your perspective
of course thank you so um thank you
again kirsten you definitely need to
check out her podcast
um i have personally learned so much
from your podcast and for those of you
that are on your intuitive eating
journeys
i think it will absolutely help so so
much so thank you again for joining me
kirsten
thank you abby have a great day bottom
line
bariatric surgery may have significant
health benefits for some individuals
i am always happy that we have a wide
range of medical procedures
and options to suit a wide variety of
individuals needs
but it's also important to know that it
is not necessarily a magic pill
and is not without any risks weight loss
surgery
is ultimately a stomach surgery not a
brain surgery
so if the underlying health concerns
related to eating
and food are not well addressed before
surgery
the risks very well may outweigh the
benefits
of a smaller body again this video is
meant to inform
and support your journey not ever to
shame or belittle
anyone for their health and wellness
choices so
please help me keep the comment section
kind
and respectful now if you found this
information
enlightening please don't forget to give
this video a thumbs up
leave me a comment below if you have any
further questions about these types of
surgeries or really anything nutrition
related that you'd like a video on
subscribe to the channel don't forget
that and i will see you next time on
abby's kitchen
[Music]
bye
you